if we could open up the Sun we'd see
layers of dense hydrogen gas hundreds of
thousands of miles deep at at its center
the core the Sun gives birth to light
forged and one of the most violent
reactions in the universe
nuclear fusion the specific nuclear
reaction that powers the Sun is fusion
fusion of hydrogen into helium you take
two hydrogen atoms you RAM them together
and what's left over is a helium atom it
sounds simple enough but it's not it's
actually hard to get two atoms to fuse
two protons have the same charge they're
both positively charged they want to
repel each other protons don't like to
get close together they have to come
together with a huge amount of energy or
velocity to get close enough to begin to
fuse and that's very very rare to force
protons together takes immense amounts
of heat and pressure generated by the
invisible hand of gravity the Sun
contains ninety-nine point eight percent
of all the matter in the solar system
that's a lot of mass all that mass pulls
the Sun together with unimaginable
gravitational force both gravity
crushing things down things get close
enough together and nuclear fusion
happens in this nuclear compactor
hydrogen atom slammed together 100
million quadrillion quadrillion times
each second some of these collisions are
so powerful that atoms fuse releasing
energy when the protons come together to
bind together they lose a little bit of
mass and that mass gets converted into
energy and every second of every day
about 5 million tons of stuff is being
converted to energy it's amazing